y la burka azul de pies a cabeza era un
símbolo de los talibanes régimen de
línea dura de 1996 a 2001 ahora una vez
más está siendo impuesta para las
mujeres en afganistán un decreto emitido
por el líder supremo de los talibanes
giba tu lado dice deberían usar una
burka de pies a cabeza ya que es
tradicional y respetuoso las mujeres que
no son demasiado mayores o jóvenes deben
cubrirse la cara excepto los ojos según
las directivas de la charia esta última
decisión se suma a otras restricciones
impuestas en los últimos meses incluida
la limitación del derecho de la mujer a
viajar sin una acompañante masculino y
la prohibición a hombres y mujeres de
visitar parques al mismo tiempo los
talibanes decidieron en marzo no reabrir
las escuelas secundarias para niñas a
pesar de la promesa de hacerlo esa
decisión afectó sus esfuerzos para
obtener el reconocimiento de posibles
aportantes internacionales eeuu y otras
naciones han recortado la ayuda para el
desarrollo y han impuesto sanciones a
afganistán desde que los talibanes
tomaron el poder en agosto pasado
empujando el país hacia la ruina
económica